welcome back to new rock stars this is
big
question the show that gives you too
much information about just how powerful
a cosmic
paper pusher working a nine to five in
the time stream should be
i'm marie mastros and i'm here today
with mt here he is yes
i'm so excited to meet you this is the
first time we've ever met so this is
really cool
oh my gosh we're doing it we're doing it
and it matters that it's right now
because time is like really relevant
we're all getting into the time stuff
right
you already know we already know things
are changing
in the mcu we have several new films on
the horizon and meanwhile new characters
and abilities continue to be introduced
as marvel series debut on disney plus
and that got us thinking for today's bq
how does loki and other marvel series
affect the
mcu power rankings in other words
we need to know who's on top okay who's
on top all right
let's find out who's on top of the mcu
okay because
a little over a year ago we did do an
mcu power rankings breakdown here on new
rockstar that's right question
now that we have new players on the
board and we continue to learn more
about the cosmic side of the mcu
we thought it might be a good time to
revisit those power rankings to see how
things may have shifted so in that
episode we looked at
five tiers of beings the first one being
parents and those are beings who are
mostly earthbound and or at least
originally from earth and their powers
and abilities
are mostly drawn from physical and
magical elements found on earth and tied
to this dimension
do you remember um in the original
ranking we actually put eric and phillip
uh in there they ranked each other and
philip
got 26 and eric got 30.
which is funny because philip is like
you know
phillip's a specimen that man is a
specimen yeah
a very physically buff man yeah so
so maybe at the end just for fun we can
we can re-rank them
according to these new let's do it
that's what the people want to know
so this taren tier includes the hulk we
got carol danvers we got peter quill aka
star-lord who is you know part celestial
we have a scarlet witch
and we have other characters that we
haven't even seen yet like you know kang
kang gang um doctor doom jean gray you
know like jean grey is
a very powerful lady and but she's also
part of that terran tear
okay so tier two we have the gods upon
high
call gods demons and aliens to be exact
and these characters include beings
that have you know more accents yes
more accents than usual you know more uh
shakespearean
they're all british yeah pretty much um
but these characters include beings that
have more enhanced cosmic powers and
they also tend to live
longer lives or possibly even be
immortal which is pretty great
you know because you know as a black man
i don't have much i don't have a lot of
time in this world
we're trying to get you to live as long
as possible yeah you know with all these
uh
pre-existing conditions that african
americans have i'm 29 so i'm like that's
basically
62.
and so this tier of gods demons and
aliens include
obviously thor and loki hella and odin
and they're all asgardians and i'm sure
it also includes you know
your malekiths your dark elves and all
that um then you have the collector and
the grandmaster who are the elders of
the universe who
i mean they haven't officially met yet
but like we already know that they're
the elders so
no and then we have aliens like thanos
with very beefy
daddy phantom daddy chill fake with two
two c's uh i think three c's honestly oh
my goodness yeah you're right you're
right he's a big man
very thick yeah even his chin with those
ridges oh my god
i forgot about butt chin um and then we
have characters that are soon to come
like adam warlock in the eternals in
apocalypse for example yeah and then we
have tier three
cosmic entities and these are often
beings with the ability
to traverse dimensions and a good way to
think of this tier is that they are
often
the gods of other gods in the marvel
universe and this tier includes
the celestials the little robot people
that i don't know what they're doing
they're just
people's lives up what they do is just
destroying people on a large scale
really it's being any convenience
then we have big face dormammu oh my god
yeah
very curious about what we're doing in
this dimension he should probably mind
his own business
ego the living planet who is uh very
dead now
and some other characters that we
haven't seen yet like as in the searcher
who we briefly saw but did we really see
him
what do we really know about essen right
that is
you know a lot of people's days um then
we have nightmare who was teased in loki
and then the phoenix force
x-men and galactus which is great and
then we have a tier 4 which is
conceptual cosmic entities
in this tier we find beings that are of
the physical manifestations
of concepts then this year includes the
watchers
eternity mistress love sir hate
master order lord chaos you know the
whole gang
the old cause of conceptual cosmic gang
you know we hate having bodies who needs
bodies bodies are annoying i mean
managing
my body has been the worst thing to do
over these past few hours
hasn't been great you know what i'd love
to just be a conceptual
physical team yes and then finally we
have two to five
meta entities and this final tier
includes beings like the living tribunal
and the one above all which is like you
know like stan lee jack derby kevin
feige all that
so in addition to those five teams that
we came up with we also looked at
marvel's
official power rankings and as a
reminder marvel ranks their characters
based on
six character attributes and those
attributes are
durability energy fighting intelligence
speed strength um water and heart
which is cool
i i think i made that joke last time i
got stuck no hey
you know what if it keeps working i love
it oh i know that whole
song
bro gotta take pollution down to zero
liar oh god that's uh that's the good
educational indoctrination right that's
right that's right
and so marvel likes to assign a rank
from one to seven in each of these
categories for a total max power of
a 42 and it's important to remember that
powers
and abilities can vary widely in the
comics so depending on the writer
and what is needed for the narrative
story arc etc so
still it's good to know how marvel ranks
their own characters so this is a
nice little uh gauge for all that so
that's how we're going to structure
our power rankings today and we've had
three marvel series premieres since our
other power rankings video and now it's
time to make our adjustments
and additions based on what we learned
so far so
let us start with the terence tear me
and you people
with the skin and the flesh and uh
completely non-conceptual we're actual
literal beings we're dumb idiots with
bodies yes bodies and
depression anyway
um so we have some new characters to
slay in here as well as some changes to
make
to some old friends and let's start with
the falcon in the winter soldier series
i mean
first of all who the [ __ ] is falcon i
don't know that man
that doesn't exist that's captain
america right there that's right
sammy sammy wins we have us agent
john walker also known as johnny
mayonnaise with
mental issues i don't know what's going
on with john walker but he's a weird
weird
individual anyway super soldier level
power on that man
and i don't know if his version of the
serum is any worse or better than the
irksen formula but his version of the
serum did not make any major physical
changes to his body
and he clearly has some anger issues to
work out because uh he completely
murdered that man
in broad daylight i'm still shocked that
i will never not be shocked
at that visual he and you know what
that's true because like when original
captain america took the serum he went
from real skinny to like
super buff like instantaneously to like
so it just makes you super strong
without affecting your appearance so
that is a difference that's a good note
i feel like that's like super great if
you want to keep things low-key it's
like you know what i just
i'm going to take this serum and then
i'm going to compete in sports and be
better than everyone else and no one's
going to know
let's be real though like people would
want the original serum just to be like
i just want to look good for summer
honestly yeah because like that
transformation
yeah steve went from uh skinny to uh
a man through instant puberty
everything instant instantaneous puberty
um that's great
what puberty's like but i hear it's
great just kidding i'm
a man so what so what's john walker's
number then so
marvel's official power ranking for john
walker is 28. with his highest ability
being a level six
fighting skill he's probably ranked a
little higher in the comics than he's
been presented in the mcu
that we did put up quite a fight against
sam and bucky because
you know those were not easy opponents
to fight right
he is he got his arm broke but speaking
of the falcon the winner soldier we have
bucky barnes aka the winter soldier aka
the
white wolf we love him he seems to have
left the series about the same i mean
he's got a new vibranium arm that is
theoretically stronger than his previous
titanium arm
however it does have that you know
finger punch code
that you know control off delete and it
falls off yeah it seems
like a little bit of a little bit of
that great thing to have if you you know
want to always have your arm on but
should that affect his power ranking
best dummy james tis but a scratch i
mean
he seems to have finally beaten his
brainwashing and is smiling again so
that should boost his confidence so
bucky's official power ranking in marvel
is
at a 19 with his highest attribute being
his
level six fighting skills and he's
probably a higher ranking in the mcu as
we would put him above
john walker and he caught everything jon
threw at him so you know
yeah i would say so i put him higher too
just because
when nobody wants to have john walker
above winter soldier like this is true
that's
disrespectful honestly it's wrong also
by the way all these people are lower
are lower than uh
than eric boss and philip so i mean
clearly obviously because like you know
i watch fitness origins like
everybody did yeah you know eric voss
with
uh bucky barnes instantaneously
i'm i'm calling i'm setting up a match
now
we had a big youtube boxing match let's
get eric boss
versus bucky barnes right now it'll go
down bucky barnes has no chance
my boy eric he's got the juice he's got
it and we also have of course
my boy sam wilson aka captain america
definitely a big boost in ranking for
sam this time around
because he now has a shield and he's not
afraid to use it and he also has those
bomb ass vibranium wings and full
sleeves on his
shirt which is great that's gotta be at
least three points because he's just
warmer
he's just that's what grandma says but
most importantly he has a sense of
purpose because he is
captain america now and he's going to
hold it down as
such and sam's official power ranking is
only out of 14
but that's technically for sam as falcon
right
they don't got that new captain america
uh updated power ranking yet because
it's just
it's too it's too powerful i don't think
they have a number for it yet because my
boy he's just
too strong what does a scouter say about
his power level
it's over nine thousand what nine
thousand so he should be ranked higher
in the mcu though he doesn't have that
super soldier serum in his blood right
so with all of his equipment
he would be about the same level as
bucky i would say and plus when they're
fighting side by side
they play off of each other and bucky
can't fly so
you know bucky can't fly yet yeah that's
mostly because he hasn't tried
[Music]
well so on that tarantula let's move on
over to one division
but one division
first we have creepy white vision and he
appears to have all the same abilities
as
regular red vision however he does not
have the mind stone which is you know
kind of not as cool but we'll forgive
you white vision but he also has to
learn how to interact with humanity
all over again i mean so do we kill you
white vision
we're not robots just humans yes like
you
and my boy white vision is definitely a
powerful sentient
weapon and whenever we see him again in
the mcu he's certain to have a
huge impact marvel's official power
ranking for vision is at a 27
with a six in durability and energy and
vision was always a powerful force in
the terran tier and even though this
vision lacks an infinity stone in his
head
he still packs a mighty phase-shifting
punch as we see in the finale of
hondavision but next is monika rambo
also from juan division and we don't
know the full extent of her powers yet
but what we have seen
is pretty damn impressive yeah those
bullets went right through that woman
completely through her passages in and
out of the head seemed to have unlocked
the powers within monica
or gave them to her we're not really
sure there right in the marvel comics
monika of course becomes spectrum and
has an official power
ranking of 29 with a seven in the energy
category because
that woman is all about that energy and
in the comics she has a vast array of
energy manipulation powers
and while she may not turn out to be as
powerful as carol damer's in the mcu
monica should still be considered
high up on that taren tear and then of
course we got our girl
number one stunner heck of the harkness
chilling in west view
she displayed a ton of proficiency in
magic in that show
she showed up to the hex when no other
magical beings appeared to notice
like you know yeah the sorcerer supreme
who just didn't show up
in one division like yeah strange come
on man
i know it's new jersey but like make an
effort make it make it effort bro
[Music]
she has lived a very long life so
clearly
she has a lot of knowledge and
experience and we know she has the
ability to drain the power of other
magical beings so
she was able to go toe-to-toe with the
legendary a scarlet
witch though sandwich wasn't really up
to speed on all the rules and
regulations of chaos magic so
i guess it's not really a fair full
scarlet witch fight but that's still
pretty impressive
she basically had one arm tied behind
her back and the one piece of
information that she did drop she used
to defeat her so
they were even for a while but scarlet
witch is definitely on top
oh for sure definitely now these days
because she's reading too much
now she has books books reading
huh just kidding read about kids it's
great
butterfly in the sky
[Music]
oh
[Music]
official marvel power ranking is at a 20
and that's because they gave her a seven
in speed because she can teleport which
is right pretty great
um and she also has a six in energy
thanks to her magic
proficiency and she's probably one of
the most powerful
magical beings on earth you know when
she's not stuck in the west view
yeah neighborhood prison and then we
have this is the big one folks this is
the one we got
it's the one we got you came here for
it's the scarlet witch
okay she is the big guns of the taren
tier this is a huge jump in power
rankings for the scarlet witch
this time around because we saw the
beginnings of wanda's immense power when
she blipped back in the end game and
went one-on-one
with thanos and left him absolutely
wrecked he he bitched out and he had to
call in reinforcements because
wanda was too strong for him that's why
you did but now that she's reading up on
the dark hole and has an awareness of
her
reality altering abilities could she be
the most powerful being
in the taren tier now well marvel's
official power rankings for ronda
have a rat only at 18 which is seems
kind of ridiculous to me i feel like
she's
yeah a little bit higher than 18 but you
know we'll just let that slide marvel
for now
you'll be getting emails i intend to
write a
strongly worded letter but the mcu has
established the scarlet wish to be this
magical being of legend and agatha even
said she's even more powerful than
the sorcerer supreme himself and if
she's also a nexus being in the mcu
like she is in the comics then she's
also got to be one of the most powerful
terrans if not the most powerful so they
definitely have to move up her number
because i feel like she would be
at the top yeah like a nexus being of
the entire universe with the ability to
affect
everything that's at least a 19.
yeah that's less than eric ross and
philip so
she'll get there she's almost there so a
couple more tight t-shirts
the philip can silicon let her borrow
some seizures now
let's move up to tier 2 where we have
gods demons and
aliens oh my we have loki the man
of the hour the man who has the show the
lord god of mischief
himself now this variant of loki who has
branched off from the sacred timeline in
2012
still has a lot of his magical powers
and extended lifespan that could
classify him as
a god though the tva has really shown
him his place in the hierarchy of the
cosmos when he had that existential
crisis which was
one of my favorite moments of episode 1.
even almost as sad as him seeing his mom
die
seeing himself die oh he was like give
me an acting award that whole thing he
was just like i'm acting yeah
obviously he's going for that emmy he's
going for that emmy you can feel it but
there's also the possibility that our
loki is not the strongest loki out there
with other variants potentially having
different or more powerful abilities
loki's official marvel power ranking is
at a 32 with a 7 in speed
and a 6 in both durability and energy
and
we still rank him in the lower part of
tier 2 with other beings like thanos
still leading this
tier but he's still a god burdened with
glorious purpose
glorious purpose glorious
to winning an emmy was glorious purpose
of all he may come out of the loki show
higher in the gods demons and aliens
tier than when he entered it so
you know we'll see about that now moving
on to other characters from the loki
series we now needed to make some
additions to the tier 3
cosmic entities category and we're going
to add pretty much everyone that works
for the tva in this tier so this
includes
your minutemen your hunter b15 who is
abandoned
ravonna renssler who is also a banana
she's you know a badass from the
courtroom and
from her desk in her office and then we
have
mobius who is you know a sarcastic king
owen wilson wow and they all appear to
have abilities to travel along
the sacred timeline and immobilize slash
imprison all sorts of beings you know
including loki like
b15 [ __ ] slapped the [ __ ] out of loki
in slow motion and it was glorious like
i played the slow motion
in slow motion because i just needed to
see it
i like seeing loki get what's coming to
him oh yeah i feel like people forget
that he killed so many people
so many people so many people but people
are like oh look he's sad
he didn't mean it he could get slapped a
couple times that's cool yeah like one
or two slaps that's cool and then you
can redeem yourself
yeah but all the powers of the tva seem
to come from texts applied by the tva
which itself exists in a place where
time passes differently
than no time zone we expect and it also
seems like everyone that works at the
tva was created
to work there right they were not
recruited from around the cosmos
they were specifically made to be tva
agents which is
depressing yeah he doesn't know what a
fish is
exactly casey had no idea where the fish
was because he's never seen the fish
that's so that's that's hilarious how
they have cats but like they do have no
idea what a fish is
cats have reached that level oh yeah
we're just like you know what
we're above we're above anything in the
universe cats is actually the highest
mcu scorer was a bureaucratic hierarchy
to the tva which could affect their
power rankings for example
hunter b15 has more power over her
minutemen and ravona renslayer
has more power than mobius but it's all
based on the office politics of the tva
which is
always fun to talk about when it comes
to comic books office politics
can't get enough of it honestly which
leads us to our last entry to the power
rankings
the time keepers mysterious
time keepers let's find out well they
would fit into tier four
the conceptual cosmic entities now we
haven't met the timekeepers in loki as
of yet
but those space lizards are the ones who
supposedly organized the chaos
of the multiverse into one sacred
timeline the comics established that the
timekeepers were created by
he who remains a tier 5 meta entity
and the last director of the tva from a
previous reality now if the timekeepers
are real in the mcu then they would have
to be the most powerful bees that we've
been introduced to so far
and theoretically any power that the
agents of the tva have
would have to come from the time keepers
we'll have to see how the rest of the
loki series plays out to know
if they will be the most powerful
presence in the mcu moving forward
so you know but that is our updated
power rankings
list let us know what you think in the
comments section
below were we right were we totally out
of our minds
let us know i mean i don't think the
internet is scared of like using the
comment section so i think we'll be
i think we'll get told whether we're
right or wrong it's true
whether or not i even said that i think
that they are probably already wrote the
comment down on
oh my god all right so while they're
tearing us apart uh we're gonna dive
into our bite size
questions next but first a word from
some of the folks that help us bring
you big questions do you dread on
looking your credit card statement every
month like i do
well we don't blame you well upstart can
lift that weight
from your shoulders so you can literally
feel the relief of being free
of credit card debt upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan
all online and whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment now unlike other
lenders upstart looks at more than just
your credit score like your income
and your employment history this means
that they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate upfront
for loans between one to fifty thousand
dollars
and you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
big question that is upstart.com a big
question don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent
you load amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
big question every year billions of
pounds of food
go to waste often because it doesn't
live up to the strict cosmetic standards
of grocery stores
imperfect foods is on a mission to
eliminate food waste and build a better
food system for everyone
they deliver sustainable affordable
groceries including produce
quality protein eggs and dairy and
pantry staples
straight to your door all you have to do
is sign up create your flexible
personalized grocery plan and then shop
online each week and get affordable and
sustainable groceries delivered
directly to your door with imperfect
foods it's easy to build better
groceries into your routine with
scheduled low emission
weekly deliveries that fit your
lifestyle save you time and help
the environment each week and right now
imperfect foods is offering our
listeners 20 off your first four
orders when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use the promo code
big question try imperfect foods now and
for a limited time
get 20 off your first four orders go to
imperfectfoods.com and use
big question to sign up that's 20 off
your first four orders at
imperfectboots.com offer code big
question
thank you sponsors and now it is time
for our bite size
questions and today's first bite size
question is
is kryptonite the only thing that can
kill and affect superman and this is a
question from
iaj smith24 on discord that's a great
question
yeah that's a great question so thanks
for sending it in while
pretty much everyone in the world knows
that kryptonite is superman's main
weakness right
we all know that there are other ways to
eliminate the man of steel
so okay one way is to throw
doomsday at him if you can pick him up
if you can get hold of him and pick him
up just throw it at him in the comics
doomsday was able to beat superman to
death
which is like this is true that's a big
deal it's such a rough way to go
like honestly that's my doomsday
it doesn't seem great but nothing is
over permanent death because
it's comic so you know obviously it
comes back money has to be made
yep but there are also other items
in the dc comics that appear to affect
superman's powers
um so some beings have been able to use
magic against him
his powers have also been negated by
gold kryptonite
and red sun radiation so you can take
his powers away and then he's just a
regular
but very handsome guy he's just clark
it's just handsome goofy ass clark
it's just classic you know what clark is
enough hashtag park is enough
oh my god superman also has been
susceptible to mind control in the
comics which makes sense
so you could use that against him he's
also contracted
alien diseases before so like a nasty
case of like space measles
might do it i don't know let's go with
measles how about just
sticking measles without anything else
it's it's whatever disease you want but
just put space in front of it so just
space measles
space cold what is herpes
it's also known as spurpees oh this is
okay so the last thing is that finally
actually wonder woman
could possibly kill superman if she felt
like it which she probably never would
but she
probably could if she really tried hard
um in the past she has broken his arms
she has made him bleed from his eyes she
also
cut him with an enchanted sword so those
three things
at minimum if you did all of them at the
same time like that's pretty bad
probably if she really wanted to
diana could rid the world of superman
not that she ever
would and also in justice league she
gives him
like a run for his money she like
headbutts him and
like they have a pretty good back and
forth and obviously he wins but she does
hold her own
by herself for a minute so this is very
true
i would love to see them to just go at
it in a movie like batman v superman
i would love to see superman be wonder
woman
exactly and she was just trying to
contain him she was literally not trying
to kill him
and she was doing a pretty good job she
was just trying to calm him down and
keep him contained so
if she was actually trying it would be
like the city would be in
oh my god yeah everyone it would be
terrible i hope that answers it
that was a great answer marina that was
a 10 out of 10
answer but i got another one for you
hold up hold up hold up
question two does each planet have their
own set of eternals
and deviants and this is of course
referring to the marvel universe and
this is from
civilian on a discord thank you civilian
thanks civilian um
right so these experiments choices and
the machinations of the celestials can
never
really be truly known to us mere mortals
um but we can be certain that they've
been messing around with the genetic
makeup of life forms
across the universe we don't know for
certain if like
every planet contains life and like
therefore they have their own set of
eternals and deviants but we can list
the ones that we know about
we're certain so earth has eternals
deviants and
regular old humans and then superhumans
like um
eric and phillip who have pretty high
scores higher than
uh scarlet witch um
and we have skrellos so the celestials
showed up
on the skrulls home planet 100 million
years ago and took the normal scrolls
and created deviant scrolls who have
shape-shifting abilities
and eternal skulls who were given
longevity
and superpowers so they have um scrolls
right
and challah we also have which are
celestials
i can't believe i didn't see that coming
i'm mad at myself
you had to and i'm i'm mad at myself for
not seeing it but yeah
the celestials went to holland and which
is the cree home world so when they got
there they took the blue
skinned cree right and made the creed
deviant
and create eternals so they have their
own set
also uranus there is an eternal on
uranus
the eternal on everyone's communal butt
on everyone's uranus is named euronos
who was an eternal from earth who was
banished to uranus
again the jokes just keep on coming um
on titan a lars
was an eternal from earth who went to
titan where he met
c u son who was a descendant of the
iranian eternals okay and they gave
birth to thanos
so thanos had a deviant gene right we
all know that there was a planet named
young that had eternals and thus
presumably deviants
um the eternals of young collected the
minds of their entire species
into the alien warlord grom aka the
overmind fun fact actually young is
actually
my favorite character in winnie the pooh
a little bit depressed though
um all right last one gigantis the
planet gigantis
had eternals the eternals of gigantis
and the eternals of ian were enemies
and pretty much wiped each other out
they may have had deviants as well it's
not for sure so those are the ones that
that we know about but again who knows
how many planets those celestials like
messed around with so
those are your basic answers and i'm
sure i pronounced them all wrong like no
one really knows
what any of these even sound like just
klingons we only know what klingon
sounds
it's only klingon is uh crystal clear
like
anybody can learn klingon mt guess what
time was
what time is it it's time for books to
start a box of scraps
these boxes scraps that's the time for
boxes crabs
boxes crabs and today's boxer scraps
inquiry is with so many star wars
characters getting their own series what
is one
star wars character you want to see get
a series of their own
this is from janna's julie juice julie
just
julie juice i must say julie juice thank
you janice julie
julia juice that's a great name great
name great question
that's like actually a really good
question in attack of the clones
one of the naboo royal handmaidens
okay who gets killed is named corday
and i would like to see her
life pre getting killed
because she's obviously trained to be a
spy
she's obviously trained to take on
different identities
and like fool intergalactic nations into
like believing that she's someone that
she says she is
she knows espionage like she she
basically is just like a
space spy and that's so interesting to
me and we only see her for two seconds
and you and she
has a lot of like honor and like
loyalty because she apologizes for dying
i guess i was wrong there was no danger
at all
it's my
that's what she's concerned with is
she's like oh my god i'm so sorry i'm
dead and i can no longer serve you and
it's like this [ __ ] is loyal this [ __ ]
is skilled
i need to know what she did before this
i want to see her training i want to see
your previous missions
i want to see all that so that's that's
my wow
i might really dig that answer i would
have never thought of that and before
you even said that
i would have never even thought of that
as a possibility so like
now i'm all i'm 100 on board she's
basically black widow of
of uh of star wars basically naboo black
widow
yeah the black widow
i think my um answer is going to be dr
aphra from the marvel comics well the
star wars comics
and if you guys don't know who dr aphra
is dr aphra is a space archaeologist who
goes out
on these weird adventures with her you
know murderous c-3po robot
and murderous r2d2 robot and like she
just goes on these wild you know
archaeological find adventures and
[ __ ] and she's also like this weird
space criminal at the same time
she's super that's cool and she's super
awesome if you guys haven't read the dr
aphra comics they are
fantastic and i i have a feeling that
she's going to appear on the mandalorian
or something oh
cause like she's just cool she's a cool
ass character yeah
but yes dr aphra show let's get it she's
like space
indiana jones that's exactly what it is
it's exactly what it is she's space
indiana jones
and like that sounds sick i just
especially the female characters in star
wars i feel like to get all of their
best stuff
in the comics or the written material so
like let's just bring that
[ __ ] to the screen let's get some girl
power man i'm all about it yeah about it
yeah we both pick female characters
[ __ ] yeah guys that's it for a big
question um thank you to mt
for joining me on this episode um follow
him and mastertainment it's so great to
have you here
yeah yeah go ahead and follow me on
mastertainment tweet a lot of weird [ __ ]
it's
really random and i'm sorry in advance
so follow me make sure to follow new
rockstars
and send us your big questions using the
hashtag
bigquestion subscribe to this podcast
feed
and give us a nice rating and review be
nice
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube hit that notification bell i'm
marina mastros follow me at marina
masteros i
tweet almost nothing that you're going
to be interested in
but do it anyway give it a shot give it
a shot
thanks guys thanks everybody
[Music]
you